thank you very much i thank the
organizers for inviting me i expect this
talk will not be too different from uh
well it will be but not too far away
from the audience it is somehow it is
related to saugata stock in the sense
that it's also related with
p and np
but instead of
complicated chiefs
what i want to introduce is simple
numerical analysis
so let me i will divide the talk in two
parts first part is a background and the
second part is the theory itself so let
me begin with the background
one good starting point this are not a
paper published by
lenore mike and steve in 1989
that was a theory of computation and
complexity of the real numbers okay
uh
two uh basic things that were introduced
on that uh paper were the class p
over the rails and the class np over the
reels that essentially were meant to
capture the notion of probable problems
that are
efficiently solvable
over the reels
and np problems that we believe they are
not efficiently solvable over the reels
but we don't have a proof right now now
the last uh
section of that paper contains some open
problems and open questions and the last
question in this last section said the
following finally to bring machines over
the reels closer to the subject of
numerical analysis it would be useful to
incorporate round off error condition
numbers and approximate solutions into
our development so
this is what i would
what i attempt to do
uh so let me remind you a little bit
what do we understand by floating point
computations essentially computers when
they they work they they work with the
numbers that have this form so they have
t bits uh so zeros and ones i work in
base two
and uh
and then uh this is a mantissa and then
here comes two to the e where is an
exponent that is an absolute value
bounded by a certain value e max so the
number the real numbers that are somehow
represented in this way
fall into these two intervals
union zero and we call these two
intervals union series the range of this
number uh system okay there is uh
uh
some quantity called the unit roundoff
or the epsilon machine sometimes that is
two to the minus t this t here
uh there is a rounding function
that any number
in the range of the system is rounded
into
a
number in the system so that uh when i
round x what i obtain is x times one
plus delta for some delta that has
absolute value at most the epsilon
machine the the unit round off okay
uh
once i have that i can define some sort
of floating point arithmetic because
to any of the four arithmetic operations
i can replace it by a tridle operation a
floating point operation such that i
operate
two uh
let's say uh numbers floating point
numbers if you want and what i do is i
do the true operation
and then i round again so if i have
let's say
two numbers that have each of them 20
bits i multiply them i obtain a number
that has 40 bits and then i chop the
last 20 and i am 20 bits again okay
uh sometimes there is a in in most
theoretical analysis there is this
hypothesis hidden hypothesis of
unrestricted exponents so
really
we assume that
uh this max equals e max equals
infinity uh
and this is related with some overflow
and underflow which are sort of rare
phenomena okay
so stability and conditions
we want to
analyze how errors accumulate in an
algorithm in a computation and this
depends on essentially two things
first how sensitive is the result of the
computed function to perturbation of the
data d
and then the answer to this is the
condition
for this problem and this data okay it
depends on the problem and the data and
then we have just seen one example in
what
peter explained to us a few minutes ago
okay the second is how badly does the
algorithm at hand accumulate errors okay
and then there is this stability
analysis that depends
uh mostly on the algorithm at hand so
this will depend on the algorithm at
hand and the dimension of the data okay
so let me give you one example so that
so take linear equation solving i am
giving a and b and i want to compute x
which is a inverse times b
so
assume unrestricted exponents then in
that case the conditional number
of this data which depends on your name
but such is life
uh is called kappa of a and this norm of
a times the norm inverse
norm of a inverse
and
the
the typical result for a specific
algorithm in this case
uh householder qr decomposition says
that the solution x twiddle that we
compute satisfies for some constant c
that this relative error is bounded by c
n cubed
epsilon machine
condition number of a times a plus a
factor that is negligible so you see
here there is the condition number that
depends on the my data and then this is
essentially if i start with this
precision this is uh
this cn cube is what will
depend on our algorithm in this case our
qr decomposition
an important remark
that i think the first example i have is
that hestinius and stifel showed that
very very shortly after this condition
number was introduced that was
introduced by turing and von neumann by
the way
plays a role also in complexity analysis
so for many many algorithms
the number of iterations that we need to
do depends on how well conditioned is my
data
okay and this is key to keep it in mind
now what is condition exactly well
it's it's difficult to define because
diff different problems
will
carry on different definitions of
conditions so for instance take a
decisional problem a problem that the
answer is either yes or no if i take a
data d that is on the yes side
uh small
variations of perturbations of d will
produce no change in the answer so it
really doesn't make sense to talk about
condition
in this way for decisional problems what
we somehow observe is that the distance
to the boundary between yes and no
plays a role in understanding how fast
my algorithm works or
how many how much precision do i need to
find uh
a correct answer so
keep in mind let's say that condition
numbers are defined ad hoc
now let's go for the theory
decision problems first we need to
define which sort of problems we will
deal with and we will just consider
decision problems
one important thing for decision
problems is that data has two sort of
components right discrete and continuous
okay you are given a polynomial and then
the the degrees of the monomials will be
repeated or you know discrete data but
the coefficients of the polynomial is
continuous data so you will somehow have
to use both sort of data okay
for me a decision problem is a pair a mu
where a is a subset of the data
i identify with the yes side
and
mu
is any function from i into one infinity
and i call mu the condition number okay
i denote by sigma the set u x such that
mu
u
or x equals infinity
and we say that elements in sigma are
ill pose in general this sigma will
contain this boundary
this boundary needs to be opposed
because arbitrarily small perturbations
will change my my answer so i i cannot
hope to solve with finite precision
uh
the problem at those points on the
boundary
now one important thing here
different condition numbers for the same
subset a
define different decision problems okay
this is acting to the situation in
classical
that is both discrete and infinite
precision vss complexity theory where
different encodings for the intended
input
define and sometimes radically different
problems okay synch on let's say does a
polynomial have a zero
well yes this is a problem that is well
defined but this from a complexity point
of view it's not the same whether the
polynomial is given in dense
representation or as a straight line
program right
this discharge element is over i
integers or
infinitely i don't understand what what
this is the joint union of our infinity
disjoint union of
integers
yeah yeah
yeah integers
so these are vectors vectors of real
numbers and vectors of beats so your
data is given as a finite number of bits
and the finite number of real numbers
okay
which is what you need for whatever
describing polynomials weighted graphs
so
the the data we consider is the data in
the previous
transparency what about machines well a
finite precision bss machine is a bss
machine performing final precision
computations
that's very simple definition we only
need to say what are finite precision
computations so we fix a number
you match your machine between 0 and 1
the unit round off and then in a
u-mash computation
i simply perform the computation and at
every step of the computation i replace
i replace
any number z that i am obtaining in the
computation
by uh
some
floating of z which is defined in this
way
but this is for some delta so it can be
anything
i i don't
i am not taking any specific
rounding function can be anything as
long as it satisfies this
equality
okay so
i will define this is very useful to
have this
k match which is the log of one divided
your machine because this k match is the
precision
of the machine it is when we talk about
infinite precision is when this k match
is infinite okay
you're not allowed to change this
precision during the course of the
computation are you
let me make it simple no
i mean the question is if you'll go over
the paper the answer is yes
but there is there is a class in which
you can change
uh
but
i won't mention it here
now what is complexity complexity is
dependence
of cost
and size
okay so i need to define size and cost
let me begin with size
i have a number of reels and a number of
reasons the number of bits so what is
the length of this data the length is
how many bits plus how many reels s plus
n
okay and what is the size
the size is the length
plus the log of the condition number so
the length is something i know a priori
and this essentially you know how many
bits and reels and floating point
numbers i need to represent my uh
my data
but
i need to add here the log of the
condition number which tells me
something about the quality of my data
in a way
so
very important if you x is post then the
size is infinity and otherwise the size
is a natural number
okay this is size what about cost there
will be two notions of cost which are
somehow natural the number of steps
performed before helping this is the
arithmetic cost how many arithmetic
operations have i performed but then it
comes a second
cost which is more delicate which is the
accuracy cost which is the smallest
value of k mash
that guarantees a correct answer
okay
so
uh i am i perform an algorithm if my
precision is too coarse so i am near
i am near the boundary if my precision
begins rounding off this data and
sending it to the other side
even if everything i do afterwards is
correct i will give the wrong answer but
if my precision is very very
fine no matter what it happens
maybe my algorithm will give me good
answer okay so the smallest value of k
match guaranteeing a good answer
is the accuracy cost
of the of this uh algorithm for this
input
this is close to the cost in practice
but this depends on
the input
yeah it's the cost of yeah yeah depends
on the input of course yeah sure
so you when you're giving an input the
the cost you can count it how many
operations will be and the accuracy cost
you cannot count it
but you can define it i mean it's there
okay and you may compute it
uh
so
clocked computations
i take two functions
arithmetic and precision and then a
decision problem is solved with cost
these two functions
when there exists a machine m satisfying
the following given any input
we with finite condition numbers so it's
not ill post
uh
the arithmetic cost
let me put it yeah the arithmetic cost
uh on this input
uh of the computation of m
is bounded by uh
the function arithmetic on the length
and the precision
furthermore
if the precision is bigger
than this function on the size
then all computations of n correctly
decide whether the input is in the set
so two
two remarks here first computations are
clocked that is
the arithmetic cost is bounded by a
function on two parameters which are
immediately available i know the length
of my input and i know which is the
precision that my machine is working at
that time okay so this is good
this is good i know apparently how long
will it take for the machine to stop
this is bad
computations are unreliable there is no
guarantee that the precision used is
enough to ensure a correct output so
even for exact computations
correctness is not guaranteed
okay
but this is something that if i work
with finite precision i will have to
learn to live with i mean there is no
magical potion
not even harry potter can solve that
okay let me skip this
so let me now go to p
what will be p
i will call this p row uh
p with round off and i said that the
decision problem belongs to round off p
so round off polynomial cost
when
precision the funded precision before
is bounded by a polynomial function
so i if my precision is
more than a certain polynomial
if my k match is bigger than a certain
polynomial
in in the size of my input i am sure my
answer will be good
and second the function
uh arithmetic in the length of ux and
the precision of the size
is bounded by a polynomial in the size
okay so
when this happens it means that
you know looking at the beat world
that
you do a
polynomial time
bit computation
and you get the right answer in the
right time
every single polynomial
there is a subclass that is interesting
which is the following
um is the same as before but here i
don't put k machine
so
the time is always the same independent
on the precision
let me give you a couple of examples as
you might give your matrix and they want
to know whether the determinant is
positive
okay you will compute the determinant
these will take you order of n cubed
your matrix is n times n and the the
time of doing the computation of the
determinant the number of arithmetic
operations will be independent on the um
on the
uh precision you are using
okay
now for some other algorithms
the time of computation somehow depends
on the
on the
condition of your
uh
data and then what you do essentially is
you guess a certain condition and you
you set up the precision depending on
the condition you guessed
okay
obviously
p
direct
or inclu is included in this p
round off
the inclusion is strict yeah the
inclusion is free
obviously
you can no it's it's not obvious but
it's easy
it's not obvious but it's easy yeah it
is easy
so let me give you an example very
important example of problem in p direct
take c an algebraic circuit n input
gates one output gate and i consider the
function from r to the n into r computed
by the circuit the circuit has
arithmetic gates under some sort of sign
gates or
yes sign gates let's call it
okay
and um and then i consider the set the
subset of r to the n
of the points
that this function is greater or equal
than zero
and let's say i want to decide
whether
given a circuit uh
c and a point x
uh
fc of x is greater or equal than zero
okay
so i am given c
i am given x and i want to decide x
belongs to a c
okay
now this is just
the set
so to speak i need to define the
condition
in order to define the condition i
define row eval of c x
which is
well if x
is in in sc is a supremum over
all epsilon such that all epsilon
evaluations epsilon evaluations is like
uh excellent computations you you do the
evaluation of the circuit and you allow
for errors relative errors up to epsilon
just like the umash
before okay the same thing
all epsilon evaluations yield the good
answer
and if it's if it doesn't belong all
epsilon evaluations still yield the good
answers true already okay
then we take as condition number
the following
one divided by this
uh maximum
non-deterministic oh and
theorem this is in pdr
non-deterministic polynomial cost
uh
well
essentially in these classical cases
over the beats and over the reels
uh those are data for which we want to
we want to check whether we can check
um
in polynomial time approve
okay so
data that have short proofs
now short here means small length
and
here it's unclear what show proofs will
be
one possibility small length plus small
condition there is another which is
asking small length plus small condition
plus small magnitude and this
if i had time i would explain
um
let me start with the class npu the
unbounded
and then the idea is a problem is here
well this is the definition essentially
what i said is that if the data has
is in the set then there exists a
witness a proof
in r2dm where n is simply a polynomial
in the length
such that
this triple
belongs to a
set which is in p
in p rho
and the log of the condition number is
bounded by a polynomial in the log of
the condition number
uh of ux but you see i have a set w
which is the one that will be in np and
the set b which is the one that will be
in p
and what i said is that
when i add my witness the condition
doesn't grow much
my condition on top
and if it's not
in w then no matter which y i take it
out to the m u x y is not in b
and the log of the condition is also
smaller or equal than the log of the
condition
below the log of the condition with the
y
is bounded with a locative condition
below
so all candidates of proof are short
one example would be circuit visibility
same input just a circuit
but now i don't what i want to know is
whether there is a y such that y belongs
to a c
okay
and then what i do to define the
condition number for this problem is i
define a row feasibility of c which is
the supremum
over all
y's that belong of this row eval
if this set here
this condition here is feasible
and if it's not feasible i take the
infimum
so in the feasible case mu fist is the
condition of the best condition solution
and in the infeasible case it is the
condition of the worst condition point
in order to the end
okay because this worst condition point
is the one that if i do a small
perturbation
will become a solution
okay
so preposition
this belongs here
and preposition p rho is included in np
there is a notion of reduction i will
skip it but
i will simply say that this notion of
reduction
satisfies the
nice
property which is
uh
that if a problem w reduces to a problem
s
and this is in p
then w is also in p
so one defines
hardness and completeness in the usual
way a problem is hard in a class if all
the problems in the class reduces to it
it is complete if in addition it belongs
to the class and then the theorem is
that this problem
is actually complete in this class okay
uh
as a corollary
these two classes
coincide if and only we can
solve this problem
in p row
we don't know whether this is true and
we believe it isn't okay
uh
just do okay
maybe we stop here
no
no
no noise
i mean
well
in this np
i didn't define it but let me go here uh
as i mentioned there are two
this this np b
uh your guesses in a way have small
magnitude means some sort of
bounded condition they will be in some
bounded region and then the funny thing
is that i also have completeness here i
also have an np complete problem here
and here i can prove that this is
strictly included in exponential time
but this inclusion
sorry this inclusion here although i
believe it is true
uh i couldn't prove it right now and
essentially it will boil down to take
your algorithm which is an infinite
precision algorithm that solves
this problem in the right amount of time
and do a
fixed
finite precision analysis of your
algorithm but this sounds
scary
so i have a somehow avoided doing it
so maybe can you recall the different
between the b and the new version of the
mp so
what is that
i didn't is that i skipped that so i
cannot recall it i should have to
explain it
and then pascal will hate you
so maybe that's a question
it's a question then you're allowed to
show it now no but no question what is
the difference between the b and the
units so essentially
should we pay attention at the time uh
okay
can i ask it afterwards yeah all right
um
you